termina quédate en México el programa
que retenía a migrantes en la frontera
mexicana mientras esperaban respuestas a
sus solicitud de asilo en Estados Unidos
el gobierno de México a través de la
cr-e ha venido verificando que se
otorgue la atención humanitaria
necesaria a las personas migrantes
participantes en el programa y seguirá
garantizando su adecuada Estancia y
protección en territorio nacional este
plan fue implementado por Donald Trump
su sucesor Joe biden intentó eliminarlo
pero el estado de Texas impugnó la
decisión y fue restaurado hasta junio de
2021 cuando el tribunal supremo
finalmente dio la razón a la
administración vaiden el 8 de agosto el
departamento de seguridad nacional ya
había informado que empezaba el fin de
quédate en México
cómo ha dicho el secretario mallorca si
el mpp tiene fallas endémicas impone
costos humanos sin justificables y sus
trae recursos y personal de otros
esfuerzos prioritarios para asegurar
nuestra frontera
quédate en México ha impactado en más de
75.000 personas desde 2019 la mayoría
Durante la era Trump para el comité
internacional de rescate violaba el
derecho de las personas de Buscar asilo
así vivían la espera los migrantes
llevan con mentiras con puras me
ntiras nunca avanza
y pues deberían de ver
el Exacto esta medida se enmarca semanas
después de un acuerdo entre Estados
Unidos y México para una nueva política
migratoria los venezolanos que se han
detenidos en la frontera serán devueltos
a México y se habilitarán 24.000 visas
por vía aérea algo que podría extenderse
a otras nacionalidades de la región